[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravie de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du skyco le
magazine qui vous raconte les aventures
économiques du territoire de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines et aujourd'hui
pour cette édition nous sommes sur
l'édition 2023 de Spring Paris-Saclay à
HEC Paris à jouer en Joseph le
rendez-vous des acteurs économiques du
pôle d'innovation de Paris Saclay et
comme chaque année 50 ans en Yvelines
est présent sur ce rendez-vous à travers
ces grands groupes ces startups ses
centres de recherche ou encore son
incubateur le ski cube c'est au
programme de ce 60e numéro du skyco
comme chaque année 50 ans en Yvelines et
bien représenté au spring Paris-Saclay
de startups engagées dans l'innovation
spatiale et une société dans la
cybersécurité troisième édition du
programme entrepreneuriat pour tous le
ski cube recherche actuellement des
candidats pour la prochaine session de
septembre 2023 objectif Acquérir les
clés pour devenir entrepreneur enfin
découverte du site réseau de transport
d'électricité basé à montigny-le
-bretonneux une implantation historique
et stratégique pour l'alimentation
électrique de la Normandie et de
l'Île-de-France
[Musique]
constellation astrolabe et cypherol
voilà les trois start-up 50 chinoises
qui participent à cette édition 2023 de
Spring Paris-Saclay parmi elles
astrolabe et constellation ont pu
pitcher dans la catégorie newspace
devant des investisseurs ou de
potentiels partenaires et cyphero les
présents ici pour avoir des rendez-vous
pour développer aussi son business on
écoute les trois dirigeants de ces
entreprises tout de suite regardez
astrolabe la première station spatiale
laboratoire entièrement robotisé pour
faire de la recherche en microgravité
notre startup développe une
constellation de satellites de
télécommunication très innovantes afin
de permettre aux opérateurs
télécommunications aux opérateurs de
mobilité du monde entier d'offrir à
leurs clients un accès à un Internet au
débit fait le temps de latence là où les
réseaux terrestres étaient
communications ne sont pas disponibles
CFA rôle c'est une plateforme de
messagerie pose quantique
c'est à dire que ça donc on fait du mail
du chat de la visioconférence mais aussi
de l'inscription de fichiers localement
qui est qui résiste à une attaque
quantique
rencontrer des investisseurs rencontrer
des partenaires rencontrer de potentiels
du plateau de plateau de Paris Saclay de
se faire connaître mais aussi de
rencontrer les acteurs et l'écosystème
qui est navigue autour de la
cybersécurité et de la technologie
diptèques en général et d'être mis en
relation avec les acteurs des
partenaires industriels des partenaires
académiques des investisseurs qui vont
nous aider à contribuer au projet et à
ne faire à nous faire grandir
très bien on a pitché ce matin super
intéressant qu'on a pris des contacts
avec des
capitales des gens et des investisseurs
mais aussi des gens qui sont des
potentiels clients et le reste de
l'après-midi risque d'être dédié à plus
d'activité de networking avec tous les
acteurs présents aujourd'hui
spring Paris-Saclay un rendez-vous
incontournable pour l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et notamment
pour l'incubateur skikub et pour en
parler nous sommes avec Valérie Cariou
la responsable incubation de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines bonjour
bonjour Nicolas alors pourquoi c'est
important pour vous d'être chaque année
présent sur cet événement sprint Paris
c'est vraiment le rendez-vous
incontournable de Paris Saclay c'est une
formidable mise en avant de cet
écosystème scientifique et technologique
de rentational c'est donner de la
visibilité au visée d'entreprise
start-up du territoire une visibilité
nationale et internationale et il y a
trois startups qui ont été sélectionnés
dans ce fameux concours spring 50 pour
pitcher sur cet événement est-ce qu'on
peut dire quelques mots on les a déjà
rencontrés est-ce qu'on peut dire
quelques mots sur ces startups est-ce
que ça représente pour l'incubateur
alors nous sommes très fiers cette année
nous avons effectivement trois startups
qui ont été sélectionnées à Spring 50 de
startups dans le spatial le new space
est vraiment un axe fort pour 50 ans en
Yvelines et fait partie des thématiques
phares de cet événement donc
constellation technologique et
astrolables et notre start-up dans le
domaine dans la cybersécurité qui essaye
parlogue alors c'est forcément des
startups qui témoignent de l'intérêt de
surtout l'utilité d'avoir ce qui cube
l'incubateur sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et d'ailleurs
il y a un appel à candidature en cours
pour la prochaine promotion qui vont
intégrer le ski cube en septembre
exactement nous sommes en plein appel à
ambulatures donc cet appel à candidature
et à destination des start-ups ou des
porteurs de projets pour un projet
d'innovation technologique pour
l'innovation de service dont nous avons
deux programmes un programme
d'incubation pour les projets qui sont
encore en phase amont avec notamment un
prototype en cours et un programme
d'accélération pour des startups pour
déjà du chiffre d'affaires déjà des
clients donc la candidature est
ouvert jusqu'au 20 juin il y a une
réunion d'information qui aura lieu
donc il suffit de s'inscrire ou passer
nous voir ici sur notre stand 50 ans en
Église kiki agriculture technologique
new space médical aussi médical
technologique et puis on peut penser
aussi au numérique tout simplement à
cybersécurité tout ça c'est des startups
qui sont déjà présentes est-ce que vous
cherchez des sujets particuliers des
sujets un peu plus innovants dans l'air
du temps aujourd'hui alors en fait on a
la particularité d'être très ouvert donc
on a des startups dans tous les domaines
que ce soit dans les fintech
Agritech new space donc en fait le point
c'est d'avoir un projet d'innovation qui
soit pertinent qu'ils soient aussi qu'il
y a un potentiel de développement et
voilà nous serons ouverts à toute
proposition merci beaucoup Valérie
Cariou
et si vous êtes intéressé vous avez le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran pour postuler et peut-être
rejoindre le ski cube et puis on va
parler maintenant d'un autre programme
qui est lié à l'incubateur de 50 ans en
Yvelines le programme entrepreneuriat
pour tous et d'ailleurs nous avons suivi
Pascal Pascal qui a su qui a suivi en
fait la deuxième édition et la deuxième
promotion de l'entrepreneuriat pour tous
regarder cette rencontre
[Musique]
je m'appelle Pascal Le Floch dirigeant
de PLF coaching alors j'ai démarré mon
activité en février de de cette année je
fais partie je dirais d'une coopérative
qui s'appelle la forge et ça me permet
d'être au sein d'un réseau
d'entrepreneurs la Forge est situé en
fait sur le bassin de Saint-Quentin à
Coignières
j'accompagne les entrepreneurs les
dirigeants les managers avec leurs
équipes et en ce qui concerne la
formation mais là je m'appuie sur mes 17
ans de management des 25 ans de carrière
en commercial pour justement transmettre
mais savoir faire mes techniques
également donc le coach lui va faire
tout ce qu'il est en mesure de faire
pour amener son client ou sa cliente à
passer à l'action
l'aspect formation pour l'instant c'est
60% de des revenus et l'aspect coaching
qui est en augmentation représente
aujourd'hui 40% à 6 mois d'activité
c'est je dirais c'est au-delà de mes
espérances mais j'ai déjà fait des
cycles de formation pour des entreprises
internationales pour leurs équipes de
vente et par rapport à l'aspect coaching
j'ai démarré avec mon réseau direct et
le bouche à oreille fonctionne bien
puisque les premiers clients me
recommandent
[Musique]
retour sur l'événement en spring
Paris-Saclay on va parler de
l'entrepreneuriat pour tous avec Céline
boisseau bonjour bonjour vous êtes la
responsable création et développement
d'entreprise au sein du ski cube alors
on vient de voir le parcours de Pascal
Le Floch qui maintenant a créé son
entreprise PF coaching c'est un exemple
justement de réussite pour le programme
entrepreneuriat pour tous oui tout à
fait c'est un exemple de explicite
Pascal a participé à la deuxième
promotion d'entrepreneuriat pour tous
c'était même un grand frère pour pour
les autres pour les autres candidats il
était vraiment là aussi en appui donc
belle réussite parce que grâce à
entrepreneuriat pour tous il a pu créer
sa société et c'était son projet et
c'est notre but en fait dans propre
entrepreneuriat pour tous
d'accompagner en fait les personnes qui
ont un projet qui n'oserait pas se
lancer qui n'ont pas les formations
adéquates ou qui sont dans des quartiers
prioritaires de la ville et qui n'ont
pas les aides on est vraiment là pour
les accompagner et ils ont la chance
tout cette porteur de projet de savoir
qu'on est là alors comment ça se passe
combien de temps et puis commence
qu'est-ce que vous faites en fait
pendant cette durée là alors comment ça
se passe c'est une formation qui dure
250 heures donc qui se déroule sur trois
mois de mi-septembre à mi-décembre donc
au début pendant trois semaines ils ont
des formations trois semaines de
formation sont plutôt théoriques ou en
fait ils apprennent à se connaître toute
l'équipe parce que je vous ai pas dit
c'est une équipe de 12 candidats qui
apprennent à se connaître à vivre
ensemble à travailler ensemble donc
plutôt découvrir et après il y a des
formations des animations par thème sur
la communication sur le prévisionnel sur
créer son site web savoir comment
pitcher parce que c'est pas donné à tout
le monde non plus comment faire du
réseau tâche c'est vraiment une
formation complète et on a la chance
qu'elle soit financée 100% par
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et c'est pas
le cas partout alors vous parlez de
septembre prochain et justement nous
sommes en pleine session d'appels à
candidature d'ailleurs si vous nous
regardez vous pouvez postuler sur le
site qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
c'est juste à quand justement alors la
belle candidature a débuté au mois de
mai et va jusqu'au 30 juin donc il faut
absolument candidater via le Google en
forme et via en fait soit vous appelez
le ski cube et on vous dira comment
faire soit et bien en fait il y a un
petit Q sur des flyers que vous pourrez
trouver un peu partout sur
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines parce qu'on
les a distribuées et vous scanné le
flyer et vous candidater d'accord
autrement vous allez sur le LinkedIn de
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et vous
trouvez le lien pour candidater et vous
avez toutes ces informations sur le
bandeau qui s'affichent en bas de
l'écran un dernier mot est-ce qu'on est
obligé de venir et de candidater pour
avec un projet ou est-ce que le projet
peut se construire pendant la formation
alors il faut déjà avoir une bonne idée
parce qu'on va travailler sur le
prévisionnel donc si déjà on ne sait pas
la société l'idée qu'on veut ça va être
compliqué donc il faut déjà avoir une
bonne idée et avoir l'envie de créer
est-ce que je vous ai pas dit c'est que
pour pouvoir candidater il faut être
disponible parce que pendant les trois
mois ces trois jours sur 5 et il faut
surtout être motivé
merci Céline boisseau
d'entreprise et développement
d'entreprises aussi cubes et le skyeco
se poursuit au spring paris-saclic
[Musique]
et en parlant d'innovation focus
maintenant sur RTE réseau de transport
d'électricité qui digitalise de plus en
plus son activité implantée depuis une
trentaine d'années à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le site s'occupe
de l'alimentation en électricité de la
Normandie et de l'Île-de-France 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 rencontres
avec le directeur du site tout de suite
regardez cette séquence décryptage
[Musique]
je suis Stéphane Favier je suis le
directeur du Centre rte de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
[Musique]
alors ici vous êtes sur un site depuis
lequel nous pilotons nous contrôlons
nous assurons l'alimentation électrique
de la région Île-de-France et de la
région Normandie depuis un peu plus d'un
an maintenant ici sur ce site RTE
développe une activité de surveillance
des systèmes d'information de RTE une
activité de cybersécurité une activité
de pilotage des réseaux télécom de RTE
cette composante est très importante
pour RTE parce que elle permet de
sécuriser tous nos systèmes
d'information et tous nos systèmes de
contrôle du réseau électrique
[Musique]
les défis de demain c'est d'augmenter et
de monter fortement en puissance sur
l'activité de pilotage du système
industriel de RTE de surveillance cyber
de surveillance Télécom l'intelligence
artificielle est une vraie opportunité
dans les activités que l'on mène depuis
un centre comme celui-ci pourquoi parce
qu'en fait de plus en plus de paramètres
de l'alimentation électrique du réseau
vont varier on a de la production
éolienne on a de la production solaire
qui vont arriver qui dépendent
évidemment des conditions
météorologiques et qui du coup doivent
être intégrés au travers d'outils d'aide
à la décision pour les dispatcher pour
les opérateurs qui gèrent le réseau
électrique depuis ce centre
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez la retrouver
en replay sur notre site Internet ou sur
l'application mobile à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]